glamorous as it looks an actor's life is
far from easy though they're rewarded
for their work with cushy homes
luxurious wardrobes and big paychecks
performers often make physical
sacrifices for their work that many
people would balke Game of Thrones
actress sophie Turner who plays Suns a
stark on the fantasy drama series has
revealed that the HBO gig once required
her to change her real-life hygiene in a
way she described as disgusting speaking
in an interview with InStyle
Turner spoke about her character's long
locks and the way they've changed over
the years at the start of the series
when sons are still living a life of
privileged royalty her hair was kept
well styled and clean but as the show
progressed her character circumstances
got much more dire a shift which was
reflected in sons as hairstyle it was an
old just movie magic to help sell the
illusion Turner was instructed to stop
watching a hair in real life so that it
appeared as dirty greasy and grubby as
possible on the show it's been reported
that the actors of Game of Thrones have
had to occasionally quit washing their
hair in order to make their characters
look suitably medieval according to
Turner those reports are true and those
sons has always been pretty far from the
series battlefields her character is no
exception
she said for the first few seasons I was
allowed to wash my hair because I was an
aristocratic young girl towards season
five they started asking me to not wash
my hair it was really disgusting now I
wear a wig so I can wash my hair
whenever I want which is nice but yes
for a couple of years I was living with
pretty greasy hair all the buildup of
grease and grime Turner said made her
scalp uncomfortable and itchy a the
discomfort was made worse during the
series more wintry scenes with snow
machines sending tiny bits of white
paper through the air to get stuck in
her unwashed locks she said in the
interview we would have the snow
machines going so we would have little
snow paper particles that would get
stuck in the grease it was disgusting
it can always be worse a natural blonde
Turner fight her hair red to portray
sons a stark win Game of Thrones began
in 2011 she kept her hair dyed during
the series production for years briefly
experimenting with black hair during her
arc and the custody of Littlefinger
it wasn't until 2017 that the series
finally allowed her to just wear a wig
for the role sparing her the trouble of
replicating the characters occasionally
grimy look part of the reason why Game
of Thrones has resonated among so many
of you
over the years has to do with the
attention the show pays to detail and
the characters hairstyles are all a part
of that
sandesh looks have never been arbitrary
they reflect what's going on in the
characters life according to Turner
there's definitely a correlation for so
long sons as hair change season by
season depending on who was influencing
her the first few episodes she was a
northerner and winter fell and took
after a mother with a simple braid down
the back then when she went to King's
Landing it was a big decadent halo that
was very much like what the Queen wore
with Littlefinger she dyes her hair
black and wears all black then she goes
back to Winterfell and returns to her
mother's hair the actress has shared
that her favorite sons a hairstyle came
when the character was no longer being
influenced by the people around her but
instead coming into her own
as she puts it in an interview with
refinery29 sons as hair is constantly
reflecting the people she's learning
from or mimicking or inspired by at the
time when she says his prisoner she's
kind of absorbing all the manipulative
techniques as reflected in her hairstyle
and when she's finding the spirit of
Margaery in herself she wears a hair
like Marjorie I've always liked when
sanz's hair was dyed black and pulled
back in very tight taut French braids it
was her own look and something that
she'd created wig or no wig the
climactic final season of Game of
Thrones looks set to be the greasiest
one yet in a teaser trailer for final
episodes
Sansa Jon Snow and aiya stark can all be
seen with their hair slicked back away
from their faces as somewhat chic look
that Turner says comes down to chronic
neglect the actress has explained the
hairstyles saying there's been some kind
of explosion in Winterfell suddenly all
of our hair just went whoop and stayed
there the grease really helps actually
it's all just grease
they even washed their hair for so long
but they just brush it back with their
hands and it stays there's been some
gruesome genuinely stomach-churning
stuff on Game of Thrones over the years
from Joffrey Baratheon is death by
poison to the mountains smashing Oberyn
Martell skull but all that stuff has
special effects of make-believe the
realistic really gross hair from a world
before modern hygiene that's something
that actually follows the actors home
they find us repulsive I find us
repulsive check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]